I might as well kick you while you're
down some more do you guys ever does
this ever happen to you where you have
we're all night you dream about you have
dreams about one person like a random
person somebody you're not even or
romantically interested in someone
you've never even considered interesting
in the past but you wake up feeling like
you're destined to be with them because
you've had this you dream about them do
you ever get that [ __ ] have dreams
about people right so it's exactly like
that so if someone does you wrong in a
dream and in your movie wake up mad at
them like what for instance if I if if I
have a dream of him cheating on me I
wake up angry at him why'd you do that
right this guy you're drinking love I'm
just saying this am I the only one yeah
this happens to all dream where it's
like a rant look in the past I've dreamt
about when I was in a teenager I dreamt
about my swim coach who's like who was
this a fat like lardy gross [ __ ] dude
and you wake up having the feels for
them who is it
it was some guy he's married already but
he was some guy who I went to college
with that I never had any like romantic
link to but I woke up this morning
feeling like I should find him oh okay
I'm crazy maybe I'm just crazy
but then the wit the feeling wears off
as the day goes on so your we're still
dating right yeah you're my girlfriend
right yes you live with me yeah and
you're having fantasy [ __ ] fantasies
with [ __ ] some other it wasn't a [ __ ]
fantasy you know what we did we laid in
bed and stared into each other's eyes
even worse than that what is his name
Trevor his name is Trevor you swear to
god yeah if you're listening right now
oh if you even contact my girlfriend's
or text her I don't give a [ __ ] are you
a bird and you do any kind of winking
wink you know
slice [ __ ] I'll get you
I'm gonna say this to Trevor people
think that I don't know people people
look at me and they go Bob he's just a
comedian
I know [ __ ] people don't I know
people from the underworld bro you know
I know dudes that will do things to Kate
Beckinsale okay good movie
not that underworld and so you know you
laugh in my face you ridicule me right
remember this my [ __ ] phone list goes
deeper than just haha people I know
David Spade he knows aliens okay I know
David Spade you know really you had that
I don't care you want to leave me I
don't I'm just I haven't dreamt about
Morton I'm not the only one who ever
feels this way this happens at least
like three four times a year where I'm
like why the [ __ ] do I feel it's it's
like this it's like when you when I want
to use drugs I'm a recovering drug
addict and alcoholic right you think
it's thorough okay so when you go I go
god I wish I could smoke some pot
alright think it through he's still pot
what happens the next day you probably
want smoke more pot that you know you
think it through and then at six months
through in your head it the end is
always inevitably bad or off or
nightmarish okay same with women yeah I
might look at a girl while she's really
attractive but the same and then what
happens okay it's always a nightmarish
impossibility bad thing or not no it is
because the thing is is this I am one of
those that believe that it's that you
and I are not seeing each other through
random chance that there is a cosmic
universe that brought us together
because I believe that I would not have
a podcast if it wasn't for you I believe
that there are certain things that I
wouldn't have gotten in my career if it
wasn't for you because you forced me
into do doing auditions that I don't
want to do like [ __ ] problem child I
don't want to go in for a problem child
and she goes
we fought in the middle of the street
and she said go ahead and I went in I
got it I mean didn't get picked up did
the pilot I got paid really good money
okay
so my point is is that we feel like
we're all here in some sort of like
there's some sort of cosmic glue keeping
us together so I don't think that way if
you think that it's it's not that and
get out of the relationship I'm not
threatening the leave you bro yeah
you're having [ __ ] fantasy [ __ ]
dreams about other people Trevor that's
superficial and it just it belongs in
the REM part of my life yeah I don't
have dreams like that you don't have
dreams because you're depressed so you
sleep and then you remember closing your
eyes you wake up and it's a new day like
that it's nicely to me and then I hear I
mean lately I hear a dog mark and then I
hear like Cooney trying to get either in
or out of the room by ignore it it's my
cat yeah and then I I do this blame oh
well I've said you eat yeah and then I
wake up and I feel groggy hello life and
then immediately think what today
nothing I'm certain that you dream you
just don't remember any of them when you
get up sometimes I do oh so you do dream
I mean I I have reoccurring dreams that
have I had since I've been a kid oh you
have the same dreams oh yeah oh I have a
really good cool ones I have one
reoccurring I hear one of my reoccurring
dream yeah that I am so I'm on a plane
okay and it gets shipwrecked on an
island okay I'm the only one alive and
there's no food like there's it's like
an island that's an uninhabited there's
no boars or anything but what they do
have in the island right thousands of
years ago a meteor crashed in it
and it's got this reddish pink glow to
it this meteor and it kind of calls me
it's in the center of the island so I
just kind of go why am I going toward
the center there I'm hungry I should
figure out back there something that
grant I gravitate toward toward it and I
get to it and an energy out of the
meteor comes into my body right and all
of a sudden my mind my bringing
we only certain percentage of our brain
we we usually use it opens up all the
channels of my brain and also makes me
limitless limitless and also makes me
kind of psyche I'm psychic and also I
can fly I'm like a superhero yeah I see
the Superman origins yeah but no it's
not it's not that because I do things
because then when it happens is that
because now I have a prophecy
I also become you know the reason why
the meteors there is because it's a
meat-eor right that the whole there's
galaxies and there's all these alien
races and more on this than that that
was the one little there's something in
there a particle in there that they are
all looking for and I got it and it's in
me forever right and I can also see the
future and when I see is a thousand
years from now that there's gonna be a
gigantic take over from aliens to earth
so everything that I do now is to
prepare for a thousand years from now
aliens are gonna take over okay okay
okay so here's what I do number one I
don't want people to know that I have
the power so secret so what I do is I
make a [ __ ] raft out of wood and stuff
and then I flied in the middle of the
ocean and then just plop on it and I
wait for like a cargo ship to pick me up
so I want people to think that I made
this raft yeah then they take me where I
rescued yeah I go to Hawaii right and
then you and Steve and everyone comes to
see that people cry my parents are still
alive they cry welcome back but when I
start doing is is that because I'm
psychic and stuff like that I go to
Vegas and I make a lot of money yeah
because I have any money even get you
because you're not counting cards you
just have got superpowers right I just
make a whole lot of money through
gambling and then I make an underground
scientific bunker where I create number
one I can create a thing that makes
other people live forever
number two I can also I'm making
Androids - I'm doing a lot of things to
like prepare for this thing from 1,000
years from now all coming from a guy who
says he doesn't dream awesome because
it's not really a dream it's like I
dropped it but there's also in my head
right when I go to sleep I think about
it it's the same story you think about
it yeah I think about like five stories
they're all kind of in down
like that yeah that's one of them but
anyway it just keeps going like that why
do you think you think of that what is
the parallels of this reality I have
another I have a soccer one to I'll to
share negative I know that soccer one
[Music]